[Music]
hey guys
right here on minecraft we are going to
showcase to you a sneak peek into what
has been leaked
into the internet about mechagodzilla
yes it was
confirmed in the trailer that
mechagodzilla would be appearing in the
movie and yeah
there were other scenes of wren sarizawa
standing in front of a screen depicting
the statistics of the mechanized titan
but now we have new pictures of the same
person inside the head of mechagodzilla
and it looks dark
dingy but brilliant with lighting style
that of specific rim
so let's discuss more on this
mechagodzilla was created originally by
aliens that want to conquer the earth
then his later incarnations were always
of humans trying to make a robot that
can challenge
and outdo the big g which they succeed
at times
so in this upcoming movie they will go
back to that and as they have hinted in
the end credit scenes of kotm
they have already tried making these
mechanized and organic titans for
self-defense
then we saw the trailer and whoo-wee the
hype is real
mechagodzilla is seen destroying
buildings as it walks by
like a bulldozer on a sand castle city
but here now we get a new look into the
mecca yes
it will be ren series hour that will be
controlling it from inside
there are some theories already out
there that is in fact
ghidorah's skull that would be used to
become the head of the titan and yes
they could be very well true as in the
past mecha ghidorah's severed head was
used to create supermaker godzilla
so we see serezawa sitting comfortably
inside the head of the mecca
and just on top of him there's a strange
purple chandelier
oh wait that's not a chandelier from a
living room decor that's in fact the
brain of gydora
being transformed into a quantum ai
processor kind of thing
that would be capable of powering the
other systems in the robot
in the next photo we see the same thing
the quantum mecha brain of ghidorah
that is heavily connected with optical
fibers and cables along with a metal
component that seems to be holding it in
place
and also if you zoom in on the first
photo at the far right
you can see the screen where the
statistics of mechagodzilla was first
seen in the trailer
this is the confirmation that we have
been waiting for and yeah
we hope this one will have all the fancy
weapons it can have
to take down or at least challenge both
gong and godzilla in the final fight
so yeah that's about it do subscribe for
more videos like these and smash that
like button for support
as well as slap slap slap that
notification bell
for notifications and regular updates on
your cell phone
take care fam
you